[Music]
hey everybody
it's tuesday somebody said earlier they
thought it was wednesday i kind of did
too for
a minute i don't know i don't know why
probably because i'm like super tired
again i woke up from 3 30 in the morning
and i couldn't go back to sleep so yay
it's coming up all this time but yeah so
uh
yeah it's tuesday like i said uh we're
actually doing a
matinee today because i actually did
watch a new movie last night you didn't
like it though did you
no i didn't care for this movie it was
it was you know what
okay so this movie i actually saw
the trailer for it probably like a week
or two ago when i was
looking through all the new movies that
were on like amazon prime and stuff
i was like oh that looks like a
possibility you know does it look like
an interesting kind of
uh you know monster movie sort of like a
wendigo type of uh movie
and so finally last night i was like all
right well i guess i'll just pull the
trigger on it now i will say
that this came out in 2020 written and
directed by
bruce wempel he had done another movie
called monstrous
which sounds awfully familiar but i
don't know if i've seen it or not i may
have
but this one it's kind of like i didn't
know if i was gonna like it either
like for the first five or ten minutes
but then
after that it kind of like sucked me in
you know what i mean
yeah so it was one of those ones where
it just kind of like at first i was just
kind of like
i was kind of ambivalent or i was like
on the fence about it but then after a
while i started getting into it
so basically the story of this one it's
set up in the um
the adirondacks so it's all it's in the
wintertime so cinematography is like
really really nice if you kind of like
horror movies that are set in the winter
it's all snowy with all the dead trees
and stuff so it's really pretty
so it's these two guys named gus and
adam
and one of them is getting married so
uh the other one kind of takes them on
this hike up in these mountains
like as a bachelor party present type of
thing cause that's something that he's
always wanted to do
now when they get up there they are at
this cabin which i guess is at the base
of one of the trails or whatever an
airbnb whatever it is
and like the guy that owns the cabin
seems like he has a lot of stuff about
the wendigo or he's really into like the
when to go legend so they kind of talk
about that and
you know how uh you know if like back in
the old days you know native american
legend was
that if you were a cannibal or you were
like a really selfish [ __ ] or
whatever it's like you could
either turn into a wendigo or get taken
over by a spirit of a wendigo
essentially
so it so happens that adam and gus
they drink a lot this one night then the
next day they kind of go out on their
hike
and this other dude that was staying at
the airbnb who's like this total [ __ ]
druggie he gave them some
uh some psychedelic tea that's just got
like
lsd and ayahuasca and just like all the
hallucinogens
in one tea so they decide that they're
gonna drink the tea
now after that one of the dudes
starts seeing is that poking can't speak
she's beating on the door
you don't close the door i'm sorry pokey
come on in
it's okay she walks in what the hell are
you hiding in here
nothing's bad going on it's okay yeah
but yeah so they all [ __ ] they trip
balls
uh one night and then one of them starts
seeing
creepy [ __ ] out in the woods like when
to go kind of [ __ ] and then i don't
really want to spoil it but there's one
uh there there's one thing that happens
that i wasn't actually really expecting
and i think that's when
i was like okay you got my interest now
because it wasn't that far into the
movie
and uh so this thing happens and then
from then on
it's kind of like a hallucinatory
i'm not really sure what it is so i'm
just saying that if you look at the
trailer the trailer kind of makes it
look like
more of a straight up monster movie
which it has monsters in it the monsters
actually kind of look like the monsters
from the descent a little bit
um at least kind of the when to go foot
soldiers i guess they are cause they
only show the wendigo like from far away
and he's just got like and he's just
this creepy silhouette like with glowing
eyes and stuff
but it's not exactly
it's kind of more like a psychological
horror movie
but they kind of leave it ambiguous as
to whether the monsters are real or not
like they totally could be or
it could just be that dude like having a
super bad trip and like he does all this
[ __ ] and like he's seeing them
you know what i mean i there there's
like there's something that happens
toward the end that leads me to believe
that the wendigos were real
but you could read it either way so like
i said go into this as
more like a psychological horror movie
where maybe the monster is
real or not but i don't know like i said
it took me
you know a few minutes to get into it
but when the after they tripped balls
and then that [ __ ] happened
i was like all right i'm on board with
this so it's like it goes back and forth
in time you're not really sure
um what really happened or what's what
you know in the dude's imagination
and [ __ ] like that but overall i don't
know i ended up like really enjoying it
i think it was like pretty short i think
it's only 88 minutes long
um like i said i think this is bruce
wimple's maybe second movie
i think he made one called monstrous but
i don't remember if i saw it or not even
though the title looks familiar
uh it's on amazon prime free if you have
amazon prime subscription and i think
it's also on to be so
it's free for everybody but uh yeah not
a bad little flick at all like i said
just don't go into it expecting like um
you know a traditional monster movie
because it's not quite like that but it
does have kind of more of like a trippy
holiday it's well made yeah they shot it
out in the snow
which is like the hardest place yeah
like i said it's upstate new york
somewhere
yeah and it looks like they're goddamn
miserable out there you know
it's shot on location so i'll give it
credit it had good acting
yeah um the story's not bad it's just
it's just not my cup of tea it's
yeah it's dialogue driven it's for me i
thought it was kind of slow
just wasn't that fun to watch um yeah
there was some
kind of creepy imagery there was stuff
that happened in it but
uh by the time all that kind of stuff
happened i didn't really care anymore
yeah he had chucked out but yeah i was
like
[Laughter]
um but you know there are certain people
that like these kind of movies you know
like i said cinema is just a thing of
opinion depends on what your tastes are
well most that are
yeah pretty much all entertainment not
to my taste really yeah which like i
said but you know i ended up enjoying it
but it did take me
10 or 15 minutes to get into the groove
of it you know what i mean and then i
was kind of like all right i'm on board
with this and then i thought it was kind
of cool
but like i said it's kind of ambiguous
so don't like expecting oh the monsters
are real or oh the monsters are not real
or
you know what i mean so and it just kind
of jumps back and forth and you don't
really know what's real now it's kind of
like
it's kind of like tripping balls
yourself a little bit
no but i'm thinking about it i'm kind of
too old for this
uh the the he's too old for this [ __ ]
the uh uh well okay
the characters the characters were they
were just the kind of guys i i don't
know i don't really
know you know to me they're kind of yet
they were kind of yuppy-ish
they were a tad and uh i don't really
care well one was kind of yuppie-ish the
one was kind of bro-ish
yeah yeah but the bro-ish guy i mean he
kind of got
his comeuppance a little bit i guess for
being that way
it kind of kind of kind of came across
as kind of just you know mainstream
kind of urban new york type guys not
really urban but more like suburban
yeah you know dudes who went to college
and [ __ ]
i'm like yeah okay he likes to [ __ ] on
people no that's not what it is
that's not what it is just
whatever louie says i saw a pretty good
movie on amazon a couple weeks ago
called the silencing that is actually on
my list of ones to
watch so maybe i don't know maybe we'll
talk about that one on the next matinee
which is like sunday or monday or
whatever
so this is kind of short so do you
actually want to talk about
uh we started re-watching spartacus
season two yeah last night yeah it's a
lot better than i remembered
it was actually it's weird because we
watched i remembered a lot of [ __ ] from
the first season
i remember he watched that i remember
eleven both seasons one and two
but seeing it again they were even
better than i remembered
yeah it's weird because he told me he's
like no we watched the whole second
season because i was like i had a weird
thing it's like i thought we
started watching the second season and
we didn't like it or we didn't finish it
yeah but he's like no no we finished it
but it's just that i didn't remember all
i remembered about it literally was that
it was like a prequel
like it was batiatus and uh and his wife
and how and it was like before spartacus
came and how bottiatis
and and that loot is how it became what
it was right and
uh kind of like it was kind of the
origin story for all that
and knowing the prequel thing i think
knowing how the story ends you you go oh
okay yeah
all right and it's why that was like
that
which is kind of funny because in season
one
certain characters appears and there's
already grudges do you know some [ __ ]
went down but you don't know what it is
yeah and i don't know if i don't know if
the first season was already written
and they just produced season two first
and swapped them around
because it doesn't really make sense why
season two is a prequel
it just doesn't it's like they were
forced to do that and i think maybe they
were because the lead
dude spartacus came down with cancer in
real life
yeah so what did they do did they say
hey let's go back and do that see
let's go do that scrap season one we
planned on scrapping let's go back and
do that
let's do that next and see if this dude
recovers you know what i meant to buy
him extra time maybe
yeah because he hadn't like come into
the picture yet right because he wasn't
in the picture yet so you weren't
you didn't need him for for all those
shots
all right it makes you wonder if they
did a prequel to see if
if the star was going to recover from
cancer well now i'm kind of
going to have to like look that up
because i'm kind of curious because i'm
like
the writers on this if they if they
indeed just like did the first season
and then it was successful and then
they're like well [ __ ] let's do a
prequel for the second then they kind of
just went back and wrote and filled in
all the gaps and stuff then they did a
really good job yeah
and then season three is the sequel to
season one
not season two and you see we started
watching season three
but i have forgotten what happened in
season one yeah so
so that's what i was thinking about we
actually got to season three and we were
like wait what the [ __ ] is going on
who's this now we see some of the cats
that some of the cast had changed
yeah uh uh they had a new spartacus
well yeah and i couldn't get used to him
and some of the people that we were
really used to in the show had been
killed off
yes in season one all right
so people had been killed off so it was
kind of like an all-new cast with couple
of the older ones still in there
and the situation had totally changed
they weren't in the gladiator business
anymore they were
in a slave revolt trying getting ready
to try to overthrow rome yeah because at
the end of
at the end of season one there was like
a big slave revolt where articus and
everybody like
[ __ ] this place the story is spartacus a
lot of it's legend but it's kind of
legend handed down through roman history
it was something that did happen there
was a gladiator
evidently named spartacus who did leave
the lead a slave
rebellion and they did defeat a couple
of roman armies but eventually
they were defeated yeah so this is based
on that
but there's so much detail in this you
know what i mean they're making it up
but they're doing they're
second grade yeah the the second season
i've noticed it's a lot
bloodier and a lot uh smuttier than the
first one i mean the first and the first
one was pretty bloody and pretty
muddy but the second one i think we
watched what like the first
three episodes last night and then i was
maybe two or three i can't remember
and um i was like holy crap i had
forgotten like how much gorier
it's pretty accurate to roman culture
from what we know of it
yeah um certain things in the fashions
of course they're kind of
dressed up they made some of the
gladiator armor and the weapons look
kind of better than they actually really
looked in real life yeah what we know
um certain things like statues
there which they showed a lot of statues
and they're in they're in the rough
they're in marble
which that's not how romans displayed
them they painted them
uh so you know there are certain things
about it that are not
totally accurate you know but it doesn't
matter they're just trying to
show you a cool ass movie well and you
don't want things to stand out that'll
take you out of the fiction you know
people are used to seeing roman statues
being like white marble they're not
using the thing that painted and if you
were painted in the thing it's like
people be like what the [ __ ] up with
that
then you lose track of what was going on
in the plot well we know what we know of
roman hairstyles they weren't all that
cool looking
yeah the romans didn't really have good
taste in hair oh
you did see a few cool haircuts you know
what i mean with the with the women
and it's a few with the men those like
the real famous ones that we know of but
there are also a lot of other statues
throughout the year that just had some
god-awful [ __ ] hair
yeah just weird [ __ ] that they wore um
but it's still cool i mean i think it
does kind of express
uh what roman culture was like um you
know what their
moral values were um if
and some would say what you want to call
them moral values they were moral values
they
rome was basically one big [ __ ] mafia
and that has its own moral values
that you know you're supposed to protect
people in your family and and allies of
the family
you're supposed to [ __ ] you're
supposed to hunt down and punish any
enemies from other families as long as
they're not above you in station
but they did that too and that's in this
in this series
they were getting out of line and
[ __ ] assassinating people in
families that were in higher rank of
them which they're not supposed to do
that
um yeah well you know i kind of feel
like well the thing about it
now that i'm thinking about it it could
be that the second season was a prequel
because the first season everybody liked
batiata so much
yeah that they're like okay we need more
of that that dude knocks it out of the
park that actor
i love that shoot he's like a terrible
terrible person
yeah but it's like everything's about
roman rhetoric and [ __ ] treachery
to to be to do you think fulfill
ambition he's a great character
yeah he's great he's [ __ ] is he good
no no no no he's not but that's not what
romans weren't trying to be good they
were trying to be great
they were just trying to achieve
dominance and wealth and high status and
honor they called it honor
you know but then there's another guy in
there who's a syrian
gladiator who ends up his name's asher
and he ends up kind of becoming the
special operations dude for the [ __ ]
for his for the family that owns him
he's a slave
but he's committing all kinds of
assassinations and breaking all kinds of
laws and doing everything to get the
damn house of body house to rise
so in a way he's kind of a lot like kind
of a lot like uh
that family's version of a [ __ ] 007
or a [ __ ] cia
agent or somebody who's and
before his ass gets killed you know by
by one of the other gladiators talking
about
that he had no honor he goes what are
you talking about this entire
[ __ ] household is built upon what
i've done i i my honor is way above
yours all that kind of [ __ ] so there is
alternate ways of looking at things
alternate values
so that's the one of the things i liked
about it you know what i mean romans did
have a very flexible
way of looking at right and wrong
you know and uh very kind of mafiosi
you know so yeah i learned a lot from it
though
it's good he learned a lot learned a lot
from that
yeah yeah that's right it didn't look
yeah
it's a good idea you know just like
that's lucy lawless is in it and it's
always nice seeing her
so we that's again it was so yeah we
needed more of batiantes and yeah
and lucy loves the character there's
lots of lots of nudity but it's kind of
stylish
in a way there's lots of [ __ ] raw
sexuality and threesomes and [ __ ]
and of course they're all live-action
porn yeah the live-action porns that
they want they want some porn to just
bring some [ __ ] beautiful slaves have
them have sex and just sit around talk
about it and jerk off and [ __ ]
they didn't have any kind of problem
with that they were just
and evidently you know that's from what
we're left from
from from history they were they were
like that um
and the more wealthy you were the more
apt you were to be like that which that
kind of stands true today
well yeah like i said there's more [ __ ]
you get away with more [ __ ] they got
away with the less rules they had to put
up with and they
definitely didn't have to deal with law
enforcement and that was the same way in
ancient rome
rich families didn't worry about law
enforcement
they didn't nobody enforced laws on them
really except
families that were above them and only
when they
[ __ ] over rich people richer than them
that's really what it was about if you
[ __ ] over people richer and more
powerful than you you'd
get [ __ ] up they had patrician
families and equestrian families and
stuff
which is their version of nobles and
nobles and nights
um just just a good series real good
um we haven't really seen season three
and four yet though
yeah but now that now that i'm more
familiar with season one or two i think
season three will be easier to
understand
what it happened yeah because we'll
remember we'll remember everything i was
kind of overwhelmed by season three
i was actually overwhelmed by season one
and two i think it had been a long time
since we had seen well season one
obviously because season two like i said
was a prequel so it had been like two
years since we had seen
yeah so i had forgotten like what had
happened i forgot who everybody was i
had forgotten everything
um louie and like uh amanda said too
that hbo has that show rome that's
actually yeah everybody people saying
about it well i'll check that it's
actually better than
spartacus okay we'll check it we'll
check yeah this is what this is one of
the first
reason this this series is old it's one
of the first of the really good
new series yeah i think the first season
came out what 2010 2011 i want to say
that one wasn't it 2008 no i'm pretty
sure the first season was either 2010 or
two yeah it was when it was when
streaming services first
really started to [ __ ] started to
roll because i thought that we saw the
first season like at on actual cable tv
on stars right because it's a stars show
i think we soldered
saw it on netflix well maybe we did they
saw it on netflix
so maybe we saw it a couple years after
yeah it had been yeah it had been out
for a year or so okay so we must have
seen it on
yes or something then um it's on amazon
prime now but yeah i'll check rome out
too
i saw eclipse from rome it looked more
um
more high-end well hbo they're kind of
like look more expensive
you know premium this one gets the job
done though it looks good it's kind of
like it's kind of like
they try to do some [ __ ] like out of 300
and stuff every now and then because
that was
that was a big influence at that time
but um
yeah i just like the acting like the
like the story [ __ ] lucy lawless is i
don't know about
50 in this and she just like it looks
fantastic i love all her wigs
yeah and i love all her outfits she
looks great nude too she looks really
good
she does she has a good she has a good
[ __ ] figure for her naked ladies in
this
we're watching
[Laughter]
she's about 50 i think and she's [ __ ]
got the body of [ __ ]
[ __ ] somebody in her 20s maybe yeah she
looks fantastic yeah like i said
somebody mentioned she was on uh she was
on ash versus evil dead too and she was
also amazing in that
man i need to re-watch all three seasons
of that one of these days i [ __ ]
loved that [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i like the part where [ __ ]
in season two there's this rich [ __ ]
that they know who [ __ ] runs through
husbands just spends up all their money
she does nothing but
merry old guys old rich dudes old rich
dudes and spends up all their money
like oh they died and then they die and
she's broke and
they gotta find another one yeah she
talks her way into their damn house
and tries to help them make money they
were having all kind of fun like [ __ ]
time
yeah talking about that she's like it's
not burning your account
[Music]
she's trying to seduce all these [ __ ]
rich dudes and trying to swing money
their way to pay for her [ __ ]
uh pay for her [ __ ] couch surfing and
then
then she tries to pay it back with a
[ __ ] threesome she starts moving in
on [ __ ] lucy lawless and then they
start turning on batianos because they
had this big [ __ ] score where they
scored [ __ ]
well it wasn't it was a sale and and the
permission to go into the bigger arenas
instead of primus
yeah yeah the [ __ ] batiatas was like
he sees
he sees it going down between the two
and they turn on him he's like oh yeah
yeah right right
that was a great day for him though
because they [ __ ] got all that money
yeah
and she brought that opium from [ __ ]
syria yeah
remember that she and they were like oh
i hadn't had this in a long time
they were [ __ ] drinking opium
laying around being [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah it's great series i liked it it is
super fun yeah you were having a good
time with it last night
because everyone is just so [ __ ] and
backstabbing oh yeah
it's treacherous fantastic the only
people that are honest are the slaves
and the gladiators for the most part
but half the slaves and half the
gladiators are pretty awed
honest the rest of them the richer they
are the more treacherous they are and
that
that's the way it really is it checks
out checks out
yeah and the in roman history roman
historians basically said the same thing
it's because you just could not acquire
power without [ __ ] people over and
without double crossing and cheating and
none of them played by the rules they
had their own rules they were like mafia
rules that's how they
so natural selection favored people who
were [ __ ] psychos
one of my favorite things i believe yeah
one of my favorite things about the
series too is that
technically it's funny because everybody
does this underhanded [ __ ]
and everybody knows that everybody does
this underhanded [ __ ] but like you're
not allowed to talk about it no it's
implied
so it's like so when they have these
conversations everything is like these
little barbed
sarcastic kind of like [ __ ] [ __ ] like
nobody comes because it's like look i
know you're [ __ ] me over and hey you
know
what come here aren't allowed to like
say it out loud there's also these like
innuendos and undertones and
undercurrents of trying to promise
something to somebody
that you know they might have a weakness
for something like
weakness for [ __ ] like it's a dude
that has weakness for [ __ ] strong
dudes like he's gay but he tries to keep
it looking
under wraps and [ __ ] so remember that
they did that yeah they did that to that
dude last night
yeah they thought that she was she was
moving in on the dude no
because she knew that he was [ __ ] gay
yeah and they didn't know that until the
end
but yeah it's all kind of this is cool
flick yeah we're gonna have to watch
some more of that this evening
yeah all right anything else that we
need to discuss
now let's go ahead and uh shut it down
we gotta [ __ ] do the shirts
yeah we gotta print these uh shirts for
[ __ ] bees nest and if i could send
them out to the damn
uh getting to the post office go to the
post office that's not [ __ ]
yeah we'll get that done this afternoon
but yeah so
we will be back tomorrow for our
wednesday party stream
without the laser because it really does
seem like the laser was what was causing
the problem
yeah because ever since we've been
streaming without the laser
i don't think it's shut down a single
time it was that laser display back
there it was too much like
information too much data trying to keep
track my little streaming thing was like
i can't take it i can't take it so
reading everybody's
live and learn centurion is pretty good
uh badger says lucy lawless is a good uh
sex
education teacher um they're saying
louis said that rome is great i'm gonna
check out rome yeah
yeah a lot of people have recommended
that so um
let me see lucy lawless is 53.
she's 53 okay so she would have been in
her 40s
yeah okay but probably 40 but probably
about 43
40 yeah i guess like that's 20. i've
seen her recently though she looks the
same
yeah i don't really remember her looking
all that different like the last time i
saw her which wasn't that long
yeah yeah all right they're saying nice
chat okay we'll see everybody tomorrow
all right tomorrow night 5 p.m eastern
standard time we have no idea we're
going to be talking about we'll figure
something out
yeah we'll have a drink and hang out
with you guys yeah
so thanks everybody for dropping by and
we'll see you tomorrow bye